bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors on va revenir sur cet
échange de prisonniers mais avant cela
un mot du nouveau gouvernement de
transition quel regard portez-vous sur
cette nouvelle équipe ministérielle
nous sommes dans le cadre de savant
dosage entre un militaire et experts
avec des politiques toutes les parties
sont représentés dans ce gouvernement il
ya du vent ne souffle nouveau dans ce
gouvernement maintenant on les verra à
la tâche il ya des doublons quelque part
le vice-président qui s'occupe des
questions sécuritaires et des questions
de défense le remise de la défense et
d'armement
ils sont tous du cnsp on va voir comment
cet attelage va se faire par contre la
question du genre est resté un peu en
marge de cette situation à savoir les
femmes son poids dans ce gouvernement et
la diaspora n'est pratiquement pas à
représenter même si d'autres par la sema
fait son entrée avec d'autres forces
mais à des protos qu'en tout cas moins
négligeable c'est la jeunesse et les
sports nous avions également d'autres
groupes signataires des accords de paix
qui sont dans ce gouvernement
on peut dire que on veut les accords d
un très bon crédit maintenant on verra
le maçon à leveaux au pied du mil
effectivement pour la réconciliation
sortie avec des élections crédibles
transparentes acceptées du tout quelles
étaient les tests dits est l'autre
composant qui est le cnt la mise en
place du cnt de consommation de
transition pour finir avec les organes
et allez maintenant au travail qu'il ya
18 mois le temps presse alors qu'on
retient aussi ce sont des militaires qui
ont qui sont désormais à la tête de
quatre ministères stratégiques quand les
leaders de la contestation populaire son
volet gay à des postes de secrétaires
d'état
on peut comprendre que les ministères
garde ses impôts stratégiques tels que
la défense la sécurité intérieure qui
est leur chasse gardée même jusque là
mais la réconciliation nationale est une
nouveauté mais non le colonel ismaël lô
guèye conseiller à 7 est à cette tâche
là on verra bien qu est-ce que les
militaires peuvent vous faire un thème
de réconciliation nationale entre les
maliens comme un peu vous recoudre le
tissu social et il ya des experts aussi
de ce côté là parmi les militaires il ya
des jeunes engagés volontaires
est ce que cette volonté se suit ceux
qui se battent sur le terrain si c'est
là qu'ils sont là aussi pour parler de
paix on verra bien ce que ça peut donner
ça peut
les de la confiance après deux
guitaristes mais encore une fois de plus
le m5 et respect en tout cas et le dis
qu'il faut être un peu
il faut mettre un peu d'eau dans la
situation et voir être équilibré pour
voir si ceux qui sont dans ce
gouvernement à répondre plus de m5 lfp
ou de l'imam mahmoud des coquillages est
en tout cas l'autorité morale du m51 afp
en tout cas tous les stars croire car
dubaï qui sont peut-être les perdre à
mêmes l'ex majorité qui ne signent pas
dans le gouvernement donc on peut dire
clairement des perdants surtout la
diaspora
l'autre actualité malienne c'est donc la
libération ce week end une centaines de
jihadistes en vue d'un échange de
prisonniers dans la balance il ya donc
l'humanitaire français se fit petrona et
le malien soumaïla cissé qui a mené ces
négociations est ce que c'est ordinaire
ce genre de tractations avec des groupes
jihadistes nous sommes dans une citation
de nouvelles mais il faut reconnaître
quand même que le gouvernement du
président ibrahim boubacar keita avait
désigné médiateur national qui est
lancée mi chemin dissocie maïga il ya
d'autres forces aussi qui interviennent
le cabinet de l'ex chef de file de
l'opposition soumaila cissé avait une
commission de médiation à ce niveau il
ya l'implication des partenaires comme
barkan la france et même la minus mans
dans cette médiation le dialogue
national et inclusive avait recommandé
le dialogue avec les djihadistes malien
hamadoun couffin et iliad agali
maintenant il ya plusieurs éléments et
paramètres qui sont dans cette
négociation
là où le bât blesse et la libération de
plusieurs dizaines de jihadistes cela
qui ont 10 ans se relaient les mêmes
quels gestes envoie-t-on sur les hommes
sur le terrain et quels gestes d'un camp
par rapport à la justice d'un pays qui a
appelé à ce fait à se reconstruire
mieux encore est ce que cela ne va pas
quand même saper le moral de ses troupes
si ce sont des des dur parmi les durs
convenait a réagi d'aucuns diront que ça
en vaut la peine parce que le chef de
file de l'opposition
et quand même retenu en otage depuis six
mois et que son chiplead rollin et
l'immunité qui vivaient parmi les siens
à gao est là depuis quatre ans donc la
poire est divisé en deux mais en tout
cas si on reste un peu perplexe par
rapport à la démarche
pourquoi
autant de prisonniers autant de
djihadistes libérer pour avoir nos
projets humanitaires
quand même qu'ils servaient les
populations de gao depuis qatar et
unique malades les bleus sont d'ailleurs
donc voilà des indications c'est qu'on
menait ce travail là c'est d'abord les
prémices du gouverement de brembo par
keita le médiateur et sophie et toute
cette médiation en dessous qui est là
avec l'amusement la france et une autres
partenaires qui sont aussi impliqués et
pour obtenir la libération de ces deux
là mais en tout cas on peut toujours et
dit toujours que ça n'est un peu gros
quand même pour obtenir leur libération
merci beaucoup d'inventeurs direct avec
nous ce matin tient bel la vie mme
bayard âge rappelle que cette
journaliste fondateur de la voix du mali